What do you think are the biggest, most important
threats to today's civilization?
I think the biggest threat to our civilization
is very much tied, in my judgement, to the
infinity of human desire that hasn't found
its proper resting place.
And so, the restlessness that characterizes
us in search for transcendence is transposed
onto created reality, and we inevitably end
up in competitive relationships, investing
the works of our hands and our own lives with
the kind of meaning that they cannot deliver.
I think, unless we learn that human beings
cannot live by bread alone, we really cannot
sufficiently understand human beings, we really
cannot save, so to speak, human beings.
We are meeting here at a time when, in Cleveland,
Ohio, there is the convention of the Republican
Party, where people are yelling that the political
opponent of the Democratic Pary, Hillary Clinton,
should be locked up.
What is your take on the political situation
here in America, coming from Croatia and knowing
a little bit about civil wars?
I'm quite fearful about the situation.
I recently spoke in Munich at Together for
Europe, a gathering of a variety of Christian
communities.
I opened my speech on the square in Munich
with a comment that the situation in Europe
today reminds me a bit of the situation just
before the civil war in former Yugoslavia,
where you had this sense of rage that had
amassed itself and was highly oppositional,
claiming its own identities and wanting to
move apart, assert itself over against others,
with very little interest in deliberation
about a common future.
What one finds in many places in Europe today,
what one finds certainly at the Republican
convention right now is a red-hot anger that
is highly oppositional, that knows how to
destroy the opponent, and therefore also knows
how to build tall walls, but does not know
how to build bridges.
As it turns out, we live in highly pluralistic
societies, and without the ability to build
bridges we are unable to survive.
I'm afraid that, in the situation where we
find ourselves today, this hightening of rhetoric,
of angry rhetoric, of destroying the enemy,
will in fact undermine our ability to live
together as a nation.
It is highly polarized; we need to heal the
nation rather than build further walls that separate us.